what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder I'm Warren Thompson
and a lot of people have had a lot to
say about the way Marvel Studios has
been going lately of course I know a lot
of people are still loving the MCU but
there have been a lot of complaints and
many people have stated that they wish
the MCU would go back to how it was
during phases one through three well it
looks like that actually might be Disney
and Marvel studios's plan or the MCU
going forward Marvel Studios president
Kevin feige has recently spoken up about
doing quality over quantity as far as
the MCU is concerned but today Disney
CEO Bob Iger spoke about the future of
their content as he called it and
franchises like Star Wars and Marvel and
if you've been enjoying phase 4 of the
MCU that is awesome there are many
projects that I have enjoyed myself
personally and I'm really looking
forward to seeing how everything is
going to come together in Phase 5 and
phase six but if you haven't enjoyed it
as much as the other phases well keep
your hopes up because based off of what
Bob Iger has said things are about to
get a lot better for the MCU and if you
are an MCU fan be sure to subscribe to
the channel and hit that notification
Bell so you don't miss out on any of the
latest videos so Bob Iger talked about a
lot of important news today but in order
to kind of understand this you have to
know what Kevin feige said a few weeks
ago because they both go hand in hand
and basically in an interview Kevin
feige was asked about the future of the
MCU when specifically talking about the
Disney Plus shows he said that we are
going to see a change soon then the
interviewer asked him if we are going to
see a change in the frequency that
Marvel Disney Plus shows are released or
if the Marvel shows are just going to be
spaced out more from now on which is
kind of the same thing Kevin feige
replied with both I think now Kevin
feige said this in an interview with ew
he specifically said the pace at which
we're putting out Disney Plus shows will
change so they can each get a chance to
shine he also said that there is so much
content out there but we want Marvel
Studios and the MCU projects to really
stand out and stand above so basically
he confirmed Marvel Studios is now going
to be focusing on quality and today Bob
Iger essentially said the same thing he
also talks about some newness as he says
coming to the MCU and the new Avengers
which we'll get to in just a bit so
today this was at the Morgan Stanley
conference where Disney CEO Bob Iger
spoke and he started off by saying this
that Disney is closely examining all
aspects of its content business across
film and TV as it plots the best path
forward in a tricky media environment
that includes a linear TV business and
decline a theatrical film business with
an uncertain future and a streaming
business that is growing but requires a
path to profitability he then said that
the company is going to be specifically
looking at how much it's spending on
content and here's where he really
speaks about what the plan is moving
forward with their content he says I'm
really pleased that the support that I'm
getting from the content creators of the
company is significant and real and it
comes in the form of reducing the
expense per content whether it's a TV
series or a film or cause have just
skyrocketed in a huge way and not a
supportable way in my opinion they all
agree to that understanding how much
volume we need reducing how much we make
so it's how much we spend on what we
make and how much we make so right here
Bob Iger states that they're going to be
reducing the content that they make and
he clarifies and goes on to say this
again he says and as we look to reduce
the content that we're creating for our
own platforms there probably are
opportunities to license to third
parties but before you go on to worry
about Marvel or Star Wars or something
like frozen being licensed to another
platform don't worry he did add that the
core franchises like Marvel Star Wars
Etc are going to remain exclusive
Disney's owned platforms but here is
where he specifically started talking
about Marvel and how they kind of had an
issue lately with phase four and Phase 5
specifically talking about the 69 drop
in the box office that Ant-Man and the
WASP quantumania did which broke a
record for the newest low from Marvel
Studios so when specifically talking
about the state of Marvel Studios and
moving forward with it he stated what we
have to look at at Marvel is not
necessarily the volume of Marvel
storytelling but how many times we go
back to the well on certain characters
sequels typically work well for us but
do you need a third or a fourth for
instance or is it time to turn to other
characters there's nothing in any way
inherently off in terms of the Marvel
Brand I think we just have to look at
what characters and what stories we are
mining and here's where he gives us a
tiny little glimpse into the future of
Marvel he States and if you look at the
trajectory of Marvel over the next five
years you'll see a lot of of newness now
we're going to turn back to the Avengers
franchise but with a whole set of
different Avengers as an example so a
lot of newness coming to the MCU pretty
soon I truly do think that Phase 5 is
going to be different than phase four
and then jumping into phase six and
phase seven it's going to get really
really exciting and I think that's where
a lot of the newness comes in now he did
say we're going to see a whole new set
of different Avengers but we pretty much
know almost everybody I would say I
think what he is specifically talking
about here is that this Avengers team is
a lot different than the original
Avengers team which is totally true but
there are some important things that are
happening that are going to change
Marvel Studios one is what we already
talked about what Bob Iger said and what
Kevin feige said they are going to
essentially reduce the content that they
are creating this gets clarified if we
revisit what Kevin feige said they are
going to produce less Disney Plus shows
now this could be good or bad depending
on your view on how the MCU has done so
far with the the Disney Plus show some
have loved every show that's come out
some haven't really liked any and some
like some and some don't I'm in the
middle there some I really love some I
really didn't like and some I'm okay
with so in my mind if we can cut out
those that just aren't good and just
keep producing the ones that are really
good and make them even better as far as
quality is concerned the MCU is going to
get a lot better plus this gives the
crew and the employees that work on each
of these projects a lot more time to
devote to one specific project rather
than having to rush to get something
done because the next project is right
around the corner which Marvel Studios
employees like visual FX engineers and
such have actually said they have spoken
up about this already so if you've been
concerned about the quality whether that
is the CGI because everybody talks about
the CGI or the storytelling as I've
talked about a little bit all of that
should be improving rather soon now of
course this is probably going to lead to
some delays we've already talked about
that in a few videos if you've happened
to miss those videos just kind of expect
some MCU delays to come for Phase 5 and
phase 6. we haven't heard anything about
any shows or movies being canceled but
most likely it's just going to be
stretched out so each project will
probably be delayed by a little bit of
course this sucks to hear but again it's
coming from a great place of Marvel
Studios trying to get better all around
at producing great content and the other
part of the newness that Bob Iger is
talking about is of course the X-Men and
the Fantastic Four he said within the
next five years well within the next
five years we're gonna be in Phase seven
which means the X-Men are coming Marvel
Studios has told us enough to where we
know that they're really saving the new
X-Men and the MCU for phase 7. after
Secret Wars and we know Phase 6 is going
to be crazy with the Fantastic Four
Avengers the Kang Dynasty and Avengers
Secret Wars so if you're a little
frustrated with Marvel just hang on
tight because I think it's about to get
insane again and if you've been loving
it this entire time then great news
you're gonna love it even more but hey
let me know all of your thoughts and
your feelings in the comments Down Below
have you liked it so far have you not
are you concerned and what are your
thoughts about this new news let us know
in the comments down below and don't
forget to like the video and subscribe
so you can stay up to date on the latest
MCU news don't forget to follow us on
Instagram and Twitter and as always
thank you all so much for watching woof
woof